every last inch of me is covered with
hair oh really
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where today's little episode will teach
you that not everything is a-okay in
Disney's fairy tale universe case in
point
one of my personal favorites Beauty and
the Beast similar to a lot of the
classic movies like Snow White and
Sleeping Beauty being the bee opens with
a storybook style preface that dumps a
whole bunch of exposition on the
audience
meaning the kiddies don't have to schlep
her a bunch of backstory before they get
to the singing teacups and promiscuous
feather-duster
in it were treated to a story about an
arrogant shallow prince living in a
castle that's visited by an old beggar
woman on a cold winter's night she's
looking for a place to stay and then
tries to trade him a rose in exchange
for a night out of the weather according
to the story he turns up his nose at her
rose and is so put off by how old and
ugly she is that he refuses to let her
in she warns him that real beauty comes
from the inside and that he shouldn't be
swayed by appearances but he's having
none of it and tells her to get lost at
that point she changes into a beautiful
sorceress and the prince sees that he's
made a huge mistake
you made a huge mistake but his
apologies come too late in punishment
for his arrogance she turns him into the
Beast so what's the theory here well
along with transforming him into a
monster the sorceress also gives him the
Rose he rejected which surprise surprise
happens to be a magical rose it comes
with a catch that it'll bloom until he
turns 21
at which point he's either had to have
found someone who loves him or he'll
stay a beast forever once that last
petal falls basically the most elaborate
hourglass ever Oh Anne before she goes
all the princes employees are turned
into cutlery because of reasons so
ashamed of his looks and with 21 as the
magic number the Beast stays locked in
his castle with all his anthropomorphic
household utensils which takes us to the
point where the movie starts and Belle
stumbles in ready for some good
old-fashioned to Stockholm Syndrome it's
unclear how much time it's taken her to
get there until Lumiere gives it away in
the song that'll be played in dinner
theaters from now until eternity
be our guest
ten years we've been rusting meeting so
much more than dusting so according to
the lyrics of the song we know that
they've been rusting as household
appliances for ten years but wait a
minute how does that make any sense
we know that when Bell shows up the Rose
has quote already begun to wilt
so we're in the homestretch towards the
beasts 21st birthday if they've been
waiting for Belle for 10 years
that means that when the old woman shows
up at his doorstep the prince was at
most 11 years old and I know where
you're gonna say in the comments but
matpat those are song lyrics they might
just be hyperbolic representations of
real story elements to which I would say
Wow
one incredibly well articulated response
for the youtube comment section but
here's my rebuttal Beauty and the Beast
is one of the best examples of a Disney
movie leaning heavily on song lyrics to
forward major plot elements it's only
through the songs in the movie that we
learn how Belle dreams of finding more
in her life how Gaston plans to hold
Belle's father hostage and how Belle and
the Beast are developing feelings for
each other Belle sings about her book
reading habits Gaston sings about his
tromping in Boots and his home
decorating abilities I mean yes this
could be a metaphor but seriously look
at the antlers he's using in his home
decor Queer Eye for the straight guy
this is not these songs aren't about
metaphor their lyrics are meant to be
taken literally they're about providing
critical information about the
characters and their story which means
Beauty and the beasts prologue isn't
talking about just a young prince it's
talking about a really young prince so
taking a look back at the movie opening
again with the prince and the old woman
we realize that the story we're being
told is far different from what actually
happened the Beast didn't start as some
jerky arrogant member of a royal family
in reality the prince who's young enough
to still be watching Power Rangers on
ironically mind you answers the door in
the middle of the night which as an
aside should actually fall on Cogsworth
as the butler hashtag bottle fail once
there this 11 year old boy finds a dirty
old woman at the front door she wants to
come in but he says no because well you
know he's a little
who's alone in the middle of the night
she probably stinks of urine and forest
wolf or something those things were so
scary she offers him a rose but he's not
interested because well can someone say
stranger danger don't accept candy or
creepy glowing floral arrangements from
strangers kiddos and knowing is half the
battle and when she turns into a
beautiful sorceress he apologizes
because he's a nice kid who didn't mean
to offend her but the sorceress
apparently has a vendetta showing no
leniency to a kid who is doing what all
responsible young kids should have done
in that situation she curses him by
making him grow up as a monster as if
puberty didn't suck enough oh and
because she's really a lot more evil
than Disney's storybook opening would
have us believe she also happens to
curse everyone else in the house because
why not
which probably be hating on some rich
folks up in this his house then over the
next 10 years he hides even more than he
would as a regular teenager during that
time he develops a grand total of zero
social skills and doesn't even know how
to begin when approaching a girl much
less getting one to fall in love with
him in a state of Arrested Development
I've made a huge mistake
he doesn't know how to react when
Belle's father shows up at the castle
and he behaves not like a rational adult
but like a petulant child which is
surprise surprise exactly what he is the
Beast isn't a monster he's not even a
bad guy he's just a little kid who never
had the chance to grow up but hey that's
just a theory of film theory and guts
and if you liked that video click the
rows to subscribe if not I'll put a
curse on you that forces you to watch
nothing but Disney toy unboxing videos
for the next 50 years and if you liked
this one click my theory on Harry Potter
not being the only chosen one by
clicking here or find out why the movie
Shrek was a big middle finger to Disney
by clicking here now if you'll excuse me
I have an expectorating contest with my
name on it
you